واحد ألف ربح الجنود
ألواح بلجيكية تستنشق الارتفاع
الصين والهند المنجم الأحمر الفاشل
داتي والألماني تومي محاولة أخرى
صعب في صبراتة على هذا المعدل إرلاش
الدولة أو القلعة رئيس إلى بيري
لأن كلينت دي ريتشي لم نعد نملكه
بالضرورة إمكانية رؤيته
أصدقاء خارج المنزل أو بغباء
أن تكون في الخارج قد طرحت
مهتمة ، لا سيما
جميل ولكن من الجميل حقًا
لتكون قادرًا على الالتقاء على الشرفة
سلمت الزائدة كما يقولون هناك هم
هل هي بلجيكا في حالة تأهب جميلة
قناني الماء بارد لكن
لا يهم ، لقد جهزنا أنفسنا
لذلك نحن سعداء جدًا بالعودة
الأنبوب السيد dsk
ما من شأنه أن يزعج plexi
في الواقع لفصل الناس بسبب
بصراحة أضع لك متر
خمسون
بعد فترة من الوقت الناس على الطاولات
حرك الكراسي الثور في النهاية أنا هنا
لا أفهم ونحن الاستثمار
إنجازات أنفسنا هكذا قلنا
بليكسي داخل التي كانت
مصنوع خصيصًا لذلك وبعد ذلك
قيل لنا لا حتى هنا بعض المال
القمامة لماذا تذهب هذه المراحيض
كل تلك الآلات الجميلة والمطرقة
غادرت احتفلت يوم الأربعاء عندما قالت
جبلي وقوي عند معدل المرجع
أظهر بلجيكا ني جراد
التفاؤل والآثار المترتبة على مشروع قانون سمارة
تعريفات coillot لإعادتها